[музика]
Привіт друзі з вами сьогодні Пані Оля та
її помічник
Совеня
Привіт друзі Я сьогодні дуже вчасно
Дякую справи Розкажіть мені
о і в мене дуже добре ну що ж ви готові
починати Ану покажіть як ви уважно
слухаєте де ваші вушка а де ваші оченята
Ви мене добре бачите точно бачите А
тепер
А тепер супер гаразд
Гаразд друзі Тож давайте ми почнемо наше
заняття і Сьогодні ми з вами поговоримо
знаєте про що Про щось таке що
з'являється в небі маю у собі сім
кольорів і надзвичайно надзвичайно
красиве що це може бути
так малюки це веселка і Сьогодні ми з
вами поговоримо про веселку
Давайте я вам покажу зображення веселки
Ось у мене є два зображення веселки
бачите вони обидва є різними і ми можемо
бачити веселку у зовсім різний спосіб
наприклад хтось з вас є у місті і
побачив веселку а хтось подивився через
вікно а хтось в цей час гуляє десь у
лісі припустимо і теж може побачити
веселку
що ж друзі ми всі можемо бачити веселку
з різних частин міста наприклад
по-різному а насправді знаєте що друзі
якщо ми бачимо навіть шматочок веселки
то насправді веселка є круглою ми лишень
бачимо з землі Її половинку або взагалі
малесенький шматочок але попри все
правильно ви бачите веселку є дуже
класно і ми всі дуже щасливі коли я бачу
правда Давайте ми з вами поговоримо
з яких кольорів складається веселка
і так червоний
помаранчевий
жовтий
зелений
блакитний
синій фіолетовий 7 кольорів веселка
складається з 7 кольорів і дуже часто ці
кольори
перетікають з одного в інший Так ми так
чітко смужки не бачимо тих кольорів
веселки але загалом ми знаємо що ці
кольори знаходяться у цих всіх смужках
друзі А що ж таке насправді веселка і як
вона з'являється давайте дізнаємось
перш за все веселка з'являється тоді
коли є такі два необхідні складники це
сонечко і дощик
веселка з'являється коли ми маємо таку
сукупність коли разом зустрічаються
сонячне світло та вода Як правило це
сонце і дощик Або перед тим як має
падати дощик ми бачимо веселку або після
того як щойно випав дощик і виходить
Сонечко Ми теж можемо бачити веселку це
знаєте така друзі хімія коли
зустрічається світло і вода також
веселку ми можемо бачити наприклад коли
стоїмо біля водоспаду і Світить сонечко
або також знаєте коли ми можемо побачити
веселку наприклад на дворі гарно погода
і ви є вдома
і можете взяти папір білий папір
поставити на підвіконня взяти склянку з
водою і зробити так аби
на підвіконні наприклад падала тінь від
склянки а сама склянка схоплювала
сонячний промінчик З віконечка і якщо в
різні боки Ось так покрутити можна також
побачити веселку чому це відбувається
перш за все ми бачимо веселку тоді коли
падає яскраве сонячне світло саме
сонячне світло є білим але коли
біле сонячне світло зустрічається з
водою або з хмаринкою в якій є багато
води то світло заломлюється
і тоді ми можемо бачити багато різних
кольорів і ті всі різні кольори які ми
бачимо у небі це насправді біле сонячне
світло яке з'являється на
різний відстані у небі бо пригадуєте
різну відстань у небі відрізняється
різною температурою ближче до землі є
тепліше вище від землі є холодніше і
відповідно коли заломлюється біле світло
ми можемо побачити багато різних
кольорів Бо насправді друзі сонячний
промінчик містить у собі абсолютно всі
кольори які ми
відео бо саме сонечко підсвічує нам
різні кольори які є на Землі Ось така
історія друзі
[музика]
А тепер Давайте я вам ще розкажу про ще
одну веселку А знаєте яку називається
вона веселка їжі або Веселкова їжа
в чому полягає суть цієї веселки а суть
в тому що є дуже багато різної їжі і вся
ця їжа різних кольорів І знаєте що друзі
за один день ми з вами маємо з'їдати їжу
різних кольорів і це є дуже добре
корисно якщо ми кожного дня з'їдаємо
кожен колір з веселки червоний
помаранчевий жовтий зелений фіолетовий
та синій басейні продукти також є так
наприклад чорний так
Ось так тому малюки пам'ятаєте що також
ми можемо побачити веселку в себе на
тарілці
зробіть вдома веселкову їжу і спробуйте
щодня їсти свою веселку з їжі ось так
[музика]
А тепер малюки Давайте ми пограємо у гру
Слухайте уважно я вам буду щось називати
А ваше завдання відповідати але давайте
ми покличемо наших сонях буде також нам
допомагати
Соня ти де Я тут слухаю про Веселку
уважно слухаю вас Ну що друзі давайте
слухаємо завдання від пані солі Отож
перше завдання
назвіть 5 зелених предметів давайте
друзі Ми подумаємо разом
кожен спочатку сам один
два три чотири п'ять
давайте тепер подумаю як
друзі Ви придумали
перший мій предмет то буде жабка
другий буде листочок третій буде броколі
четвертий буде ось цей зелений фломастер
і п'яте буде огірок супер В мене звали 5
зелених предметів дуже добре Тепер
наступне завдання назвіть щось жовте що
можна з'їсти щось жовте що можна з'їсти
щось жовте Ну я назву лимон але він дуже
кислий я не дуже його люблю але я дуже
люблю банан він теж жовтий А ви друзі
чудово
наступне завдання
назвіть коричневу тваринку
[музика]
та тваринка
а в когось назвати
супер молодці
А тепер Давайте ми з вами Зробимо ще
одне завдання але тут вже тільки друзі
будуть робити завдання гаразд
ваше завдання з'єднати колір і тваринку
Я називаю Три кольори і три тваринки А
ваше завдання з'єднати колір з твариною
Отож сірий
рожевий
помаранчевий
сірий рожевий помаранчевий А тепер
тваринки
фламінго
тигр слон А ну друзі давайте з'єднаємо
разом
дивимось уважно і з'єднуємо наші кольори
так
пам-парам-пам-пам думаємо думаємо
думаємо поїхали Отож сірий у нас хто
тепер ні дуже добре
слон молодці сірий слон далі рожевий у
нас хто
правильно Фламінго Фламінго у нас рожева
і помаранчевий хто залишився
помаранчевий смугастий тигр дуже добре
малюки Ви молодці великі молодці і
мабуть може будемо з вами завершувати
сьогоднішнє заняття так свиня Ти де о я
тут є тут
Я тут
все гаразд
ніде не дівся не спізнився Я сьогодні
великий молодець Правда ми всі великі
молодці 22 погладимо поголівці поховали
ми що ми такі молодці сьогодні і будемо
казати па-па
Привіт друзі Усім привіт з вами
науковець Соломія та Околиця Христинка
Сьогодні ми експериментуємо і для цього
нам не дуже щось треба нам всього лиш
треба два яйця два яйця і друзі одна з
цих яєць є варене а одне сире
і зараз ми з вами дещо зробимо і
дізнаємося яке стосується варне яке сире
для того щоб це дізнатися Уявіть собі ви
приходите кудись на кухні наприклад і
хочете поїсти і як дізнатися чи це яйце
варене щоб його не розбивати ти знаєш
щось
А я знаю і ми зараз з вами спробуємо Чи
це вдасться
і з цим пробуй закрутити одне яйце
не крутиться
покрутити фортеця
крутиться а це якийсь лінива правда
не дуже крутиться так друзі давайте
тепер одночасно покручу два яйця і ви
бачите яка є різниця бачите це яйце дуже
ліниве і крутитися не хоче воно хоче
спати Мабуть мені А це яйце дуже-дуже
активне так багато рухається попробуй
яке з них важче як легше здається я вже
знаю Що ти знаєш
[музика]
А як ти знаєш
поодна крутиться одне ні
добре їсти правильно варене яйце
крутиться варене яйце воно є легше і
відповідно його легше покрутити але не
тільки це в Старому яйці є Стрий жовток
і сирий білок сирий жовток це така
маленька жовта кулька Коли ми ставимо
яйце
жовток опускається вниз та як воно рідке
і відповідно змішується центр ваги через
що покрутити сире яйце є складніше а
варене яйце воно вже таке знаєте має
одну вагу 1 форму
нікуди жовток не хитається не гойдається
як в сирому яйці воно вже варене і через
те воно Ось так легко крутиться Ось так
друзі тому можете спробувати зробити
такий експеримент самостійно або
показати його своїм друзям з питаннями
адже ти знаєш де є сира яйця а де варене
Ось так друзі
Ну що ж будемо прощатися з вами гарного
вам дня па-па
[музика]